I just want to play devil's advocate for
a minute here so don't you think though
the sentiment about it's all who you
know places too much emphasis on sort of
climbing on the backs of others versus
working on the craft I think it's two
separate things okay
I mean I think that obviously your
talent is everything your voice is
everything
your skills are everything you know you
constantly have to be honing your skills
and that doesn't end until the day you
die so that to me is part of you know
half of your job in my opinion okay in
the old days when when I see the old
days I'm talking about five six years
ago when we you know were if you were a
screenwriter or screenwriter if you were
a filmmaker you were a filmmaker you
know if you were screenwriter you tried
to get representation that person tried
to get you a job you know get you
assignments and you were a working
writer if you were a filmmaking boy your
films the festivals you helped somebody
saw it maybe it's a stepping stone to
something else but now we have you know
online distribution channels we have
people trying to take that matters into
their own hands we have screenwriters
and want to be filmmakers we have
filmmakers I want to be producers we
have actors that want to be you know
they want to be filmmakers as well
everybody you know is looking to control
their own material or a lot of people
are trying to control the raw material
which is not a bad thing they don't want
to relinquish it because they feel like
it's too competitive or maybe they're
not getting the response they want to
get if you want to do that that's great
okay but I feel that it it does still
behoove you to go out there and network
and get to know people because even if
you do take matters into your own hands
and raise some money going to
Kickstarter raise $30,000 or a scream
right or you're making it short now
you're gonna you're gonna film it you
know now that you've done that who are
you showing it to you know where are you
bringing it so when I say it's not you
know it's it's as much of who you know I
don't mean that you got to know Harvey
Weinstein you know I mean I don't mean
that you know you got to get your film
to Spielberg what I'm saying is you got
to get here you have to have first of
all it's great to have a support group
that's part of it as well but then the
second thing is of course you want
somebody's can be able to move the rock
your career okay and so you need to be
networking and you know sometimes when I
say you know it's like who is it's who
you know it could be that actor on your
set who is so moved by the way that you
directed this thing and he knows
somebody and he wants to pass it along
it's building this network of
connections in the spiderweb that kind
of grows out that you know where you can
call in favors where you can maybe get
somebody to bring your material to this
person you know it is the screenwriting
example again because I you know I
operate a lot in that world a lot of
managers will say there I have three
stacks on my desk my clients people who
recommend material to me and then the
blind queries and the blind queries
probably never get read I hear it all
the time they get and they always get
pushed to the bottom okay you want to be
if you're not that first stack you want
to be in that second sack and how do you
get into that second stack well you got
to have people that are willing to go
out on a limb for you people that you
know people that you've cultivated
relationships with that are willing to
take your material to this person what
did that person or no this distributor
or no this person that runs the film
festival that is going to say yeah you
know we could sneak you in you know and
it happens all the time by the way and
that's what I mean by you know it's who
you know let's take a hypothetical
networking event let's suppose you've
connected with maybe seven people you've
received four business cards you've
followed back a bunch of people on
Twitter while you're there yeah what's
appropriate follow-up without being the
word they can tell you have an agenda
cuz you're - yeah you've got something
like hey just want to let you know it
was really nice meeting you by the way
here's the link to my craft funny ya
know too much too much and I mean and
crowdfunding again if we're gonna just
even take that example again it's all
about cultivating relationships you know
we talked a little bit off-camera but
you know you do get those people that
say hey I got five hours left in my
campaign please support me and and you
go and you look at it and they're 98
percent away from their goal and you go
you got to be kidding me
you know everybody senses desperation
everybody senses narcissism you know and
so that's kind of
easy the sentence but you get my point
everybody gets when a conversation was
kind of fake where it's like I have
really enjoyed talking to you and then
five minutes later it's hey look at my
stuff you know it's an email or a tweet
hey look at my stuff it you know it's
against all how you hand these up I
think the proper etiquette is you know
great meeting you let me know if there's
anything I can do for you or you know I
enjoyed if this if it's clear that
you're not gonna be able to do for
somebody if you happen to meet like we
said earlier like Harvey Weinstein or
Steven Spielberg you know you're not
gonna go with them and say what can I do
for you but you're gonna say you know
good luck with the next thing and if
there's ever you know if it would if it
would ever be okay you know to maybe
send you something along the way you
know would you consider that
if it was somebody at that you know
stature somebody a little lesser it just
might be keeping that conversation alive
you know checking back in with them in a
few weeks and just saying hey you know I
have something that I think might be you
know that I feels close to your
sensibilities because you did film X
before you know make it relatable you
know make it understandable to that
person and I think that you're not
always going to get the response you
want and you may not get a response at
all but I can guarantee you that if you
don't take that approach you won't get
you definitely won't get a response you
have a much better shot if you're making
that person feel human if you get on the
stand that that person is getting a
million of these you know what I mean
they're getting thinking hip all the
time especially if they met they just
got done meeting 500 people at a
festival and you're one of them okay so
how do you stand out from those 500 well
you have two chances you have one when
you face the face and then you have the
second when you follow up so if you're
you know one of 50 out of the 500 that
didn't say hey by the way can you look
at my stuff and you know then you're in
that pool of 50 now not in that bubble
of 500 and you can work your way down
from there so so if you do collect a
business card or you do follow someone
on social media right and you know
you're both on your phone so what's your
address okay yeah let me to follow you
right now a slow nice to meet you you
know and depending on the level that
they're at take it from there I think so
I think that you know again what would
you what would you say to the person if
you were face to face with them again
you know I mean like you know as you're
writing that email as you're writing
that tweet you know it's just something
that you would follow up if you ran into
him again
two days later in a coffee shop you know
is this the conversation that you would
have I think you just have to take a
real-world approach to it
and I think you always have to be
sensitive like I always say with
anything in life I always try to look at
it from the other person's perspective
and I think it's a failing of human kind
sometimes when it comes to communication
and social media in general that we
don't look at the other person's you
know schedule life in general what they
experience you know their experience is
mainly but if I'm saying that I'm saying
to myself this person's getting hit up
everywhere he or she goes I want to be
sensitive to that so I am going to
present myself in a way that makes me
feel like I'm sensitive to that
you